Android Accessories 2.0 is released since 2014
The most important update for Android accessories
I am Hailin, I am here to introduce you.
The most important three parts of Android Accessories 2.0
First, Android accessories used material design for the first time.
The new Android accessory interface features a dark surface
This makes the watch more integrated into the social environment.
It also uses the [inaudible] display to save power
We also recommend to developers
Vertical layout and reverse orientation horizontal touch screen
Swipe to end the event
Our research shows that this enables the user interface
Easier to understand
In order to develop and implement these new style designs
We introduced new user interface components
For example: wearable interface design
And a wearable loop
Please visit the official website of Android accessories.
Get more material design information
The second major update to Android Accessories 2.0 is
Watch dial involves level
Before Android Accessories 2.0
If the surface of the dial is to display data from other applications
Whether at the negotiation or technical level
Need a one-to-one agreement
In order to improve the complexity of Android Accessories 2.0 in this regard
We introduced an application interface to solve this problem.
The problem involved is the traditional noun of making watches.
For the message displayed on the surface of the dial
In addition to displaying time, date or moon phase
We extend this concept to smart watches.
So any application can publish data for the surface consumption of the dial
Surface energy of the dial
Display this data in a unique design
For application developers
This helps increase user engagement and awareness
For dial manufacturers this helps to improve usability
Now users can choose any dial surface they want
Get the data they need at the same time
Please read the dial surface and related parts of the developer documentation.
For more information
Last but not least is the independence feature --
Previous Android App 1.0 related apps
Need mobile applications to negotiate with cloud services
Android accessories 2.0 wearable apps can now use the web directly
And no longer need to install
Corresponding Android phone app
This means that the Android accessory app can access the Internet.
Even if the user is using an Apple phone
To help with application release
We also installed the Google App Center on the watch.
Now users can download apps directly on their wrists
In addition to these three improvements
Material design related aspects and independent applications
Android accessories 2.0 and many others
Aspects of improving performance
Please visit the official website of Android Accessories Developers
For more information
I am Hailin.
Happy coding
Thank you for watching
We also have a series of shows about the performance of Android accessories.
Watch these videos for more information.